it's nice to be back in america uh like
what you've done with the place
seems to be going well you're all tense
it's fine i still get tense about my
country i'm from scotland i like
explaining scotland to
some americans i'm from scotland ah so
you're english the opposite of what you
just said
stupid canadians scotland has been a bit
not necessarily rough but obviously you
know us from one movie
don't say trainspotting the other one
braveheart remember that whole movie
where we chatted about how awesome we
thought freedom was freda and freedom
and then we had a vote on freedom and we
were like
i don't like it anymore and i preferred
it when mel said it
i'm trying to be more politically
engaged i just the news confuses me
not only does the news confuse me people
who watch the news confuse me
they talking riddles oh my friends are
like daniel don't watch the news the
news is lying to you i'm like all right
cool who told you that
the other news this is already more
complicated than the house of cards
i think the news gives too much
information and i'm very aware that that
sounds like something an idiot would say
but welcome to my comedy
like it's just too it's very very
confusing i i i get
don't even get scared by the news i get
jealous of people that get scared cause
if you get scared by the news that means
you understand what's going on
president says something you're like oh
no i'm like what did he say
i watched the news like i've just joined
in on season seven of game of thrones
just there on the couch my friends being
like who's this guy
is he a bad guy oh we don't know
coco what about her she a [ __ ]
she looks like what i thought so i
called on caller
so they like kill each other and stuff
they have sex no they don't
no they don't who's he having sex with
putin no way
it's like very tense nice so i like
watching the news over here in america
it's just
it's insane i feel there's too much
information on the news sometimes
right i was watching last time i was
over here a man had murdered two people
in a park right with a gun it's
important to point that out it's a
difference between my country and yours
we have violence in the uk it's just a
bit more
stabby and obviously stabbing's bad but
for me i prefer it it's a bit more
honest
right any i could be killed from across
the street with a gun
right never have any idea who did it but
if i get stabbed
like i'm willing to take up to 40
of the blame for that
like some of that is on me like you
wanted to stab me more than i didn't
want to be stabbed at some point like
you got bare cardio you were hiding in a
tree you've earned the wallet take it
and it's not a critique of just it's the
differences i like pointing out the
differences and i'm very aware that
sometimes the differences make me sound
like the idiot
right tries to put into my american
friends we don't have guns in the uk
they're like really no guns i'm like no
of course not they're like what about
your police officers i'm like of course
our police officers don't have guns
oh yeah what do they have oh you know
sticks how do the sticks work well if
if you're being a dick the police will
go
i
stop being a dick and
90 of the time that is enough to make a
british person go oh terrible sorry i do
apologize i was
the other 10 of the time if the dick
stick is not enough to deter you from
your general dickery
i definitely went over my budget on the
word dick there right that's when police
officers in britain will get serious
they'll go into their inside pocket
bring a pen oh now you're screwed
our police officers might not take your
life but they will take your
name and give it to your mum and that's
worse than death in my experience
i go to a place called fife in scotland
right quite violent fight my favorite
statistic about fife
is that you are not more likely to be
stabbed in fife than anywhere else in
the world
but if you are stabbed in fife
you're more likely to be stabbed
repeatedly
because when we commit a crime we commit
to that crime so this man he'd murdered
two people
in a park right i think we can all agree
by and large
dick move thoroughly not cool stephen
real not cool
he went to prison for 15 years that's
the whole story that's the whole story i
gave you the entire story there in less
than five seconds
45 minutes i watched this newscaster
give a relevant information
about the murderer that didn't affect
the story the man
who murdered the two people was
described by his neighbors
as a marijuana smoking porn hoarder
don't make me like him like those are
very mixed signals
you started off by saying he was a dick
now he sounds cool